bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi des
hommages du monde entier ont salué toute
la journée la disparition de luciano
pavarotti le plus populaire des
chanteurs d'opéra avait 71 ans il est
mort d'un cancer chez lui dans sa maison
de modène en italie nicolas sarkozy
confronté à ses premières difficultés
économiques est en visite en alsace face
à une croissance plus faible que prévu
il annonce un approfondissement des
réformes
cet après-midi la banque centrale
européenne a renoncé à augmenter ses
taux d'intérêt la fin annoncée du
collège unique elle a été confirmée par
le ministre de l'éducation xavier darcos
ainsi tu es lié à 32 ans il visait à
assurer le même enseignement à tous les
élèves de la 3e à la 6e 15 millions et
demi de marocains et marocaines sont
appelés aux urnes demain ces élections
législatives pourraient marquer une
percée des islamistes modérés
mais le roi mohamed6 restera le maître
du jeu c'est une première scientifique
la grande bretagne a donné son feu vert
à la création d'embryons hybride mi
humain mi animaux il s'agit favoriser la
recherche médicale
le vatican dénonce ce site un acte
monstrueux en fait un dernier instant de
calme avant la grande mêlée du rugby les
bleus ont foulé la pelouse du stade de
france nous assisterons en direct tout à
l'heure la fin de ce journal à
l'illumination de la tour eiffel aux
couleurs du mondial
on disait de lui qu'il avait le plus
beau timbre de voix au monde
en tout cas le plus reconnaissable
luciano pavarotti fils de boulanger est
devenu ténors de légende s'est donc
éteint ce matin avec son physique de
colosse et son tempérament fougueux il
restera celui qui a popularisé l'opéra
au sein du grand public
michel mompontet
une joie
une voix comme un soleil qui se lève sur
le monde
le plus grand le roi du contre ut le
ténorissimo autant de surnoms à la
hauteur de ses excès et de son destin
et puis pour une fois à la télé il vaut
mieux pour comprendre
fermez les yeux et écoutez
non
luciano pavarotti ou la force d'un
destin et nuit il était parti de la papa
maman la boulangerie et sa ville moderne
sa ville et sa lumière modène et cet
amour du bel canto qu'on attrape là bas
comme un coup de soleil sans prêter
garde
et de là pour arriver là six décennies
plus tard new york central park écrans
géants jauger en six cent mille
spectateurs et bénéfices à la hauteur
six cent mille spectateurs mais dont la
plupart n'auraient jamais mis les pieds
à le pire à celle à sa victoire
1961 avant bien avant
en un soir le monde du bel canto prouve
son maître pour les 40 ans qui viennent
la voix est souple solaire un timbre
reconnaissable à la première note et
surtout surtout une puissance
oh
la légende est en marche
seulement 50 euros le répertoire
peut-être mais 50 interprétation
historique alors dû mettre à la scala
sans cesse sur les planches et sa
stature de géant et s'impose partout
1980 il est au sommet de son art
et de son
abba rôti un abonné du livre des records
et wii 165 rappelle à berlin soir durant
soixante sept minutes
du jamais vu quant à la mesure de sa
démesure
ilog rené fait pas que chanter il vit
aussi avec le même appétit la famille
les pattes
l'ex étoile de divorce à scandale et
remariage avec une jeunesse sa
secrétaire
en 1990 c'est le virage à l'occasion de
l'ouverture de la coupe du monde
pavarotti tous le gros lot il découvre
le concept des trois ténors
c'est le dvd guerric le plus vendu au
monde bingo les tabous tombent pavarotti
ouvrant grand la porte de l'opéra les
puristes râle le grand public en
redemande
le sting céline dion en passant par les
spice girls on se bouscule le star et de
dette
as rôti lui laisse tomber la redingote
il devient une star pop
la première de l'histoire du lyrique
jeux olympiques de turin
encore et toujours un stade peut-être
mais l'an dernier pavarotti généreux
jusqu'au bout
ce soir là devant sa voix fatiguée l'
orchestre avait été obligé de baisser
tout l'oeuvre d'un ton comme pour lui
faire un ultime marche pied vers la
gloire éternelle de l'art lyrique
on l'a compris pavarotti était une voix
mais aussi une personnalité hors du
commun c'est ce qui ressort de cette
longue interview accordée il y a
quelques années à notre chaîne il
s'était confié à eve ruggieri isabel
peichert patrick desmulie savard aussi
et c'est le chanteur de tous les
superlatifs de toutes les communions
avec le public si large qu'il avait
amené à l'opéra travail partagé qui est
plus encore
il avait cette possibilité de de nous
faire presque des transfusions de
l'émotion qu'il ressentait enchanteur il
y avait quelque chose comme ça d'énergie
de rayonnement que ce soit dans la joie
ou dans l'amont stahl gym dans le
désespoir il y avait toujours cette
netteté en fait il s'impliquait
complètement un talent en majuscules
servi par une volonté sans faille et une
concentration à toute épreuve
parenti était conscient d énergie qu il
devait mobiliser pour être le meilleur
de tous les citoyens syriens computer
depuis fin mai et où des villages
touchés revers le dvd simple
avant-hier matin étant importante de la
vita son art tribal habitat et pour tout
les alpes
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on peut dire
qu'on a perdu quelqu'un d'irremplaçable
fava rupture avec lui sa vie comme il
aimait la musique avec une voracité
bienveillant luciano pavarotti avait été
opéré l'an passé d'un cancer du pancréas
après avoir lutté contre la maladie il a
souhaité mourir dans la ville qui l'a vu
naître modène dans le nord de l'italie
sur place philippe visseyrias karine
guillaumin ils ont encore du mal à
réaliser qu'ils ne reverront plus ce
sourire tellement familier ce soir
devant la cathédrale de modène les
admirateurs de luciano pavarotti se
rassemblent petit à petit quelques mots
sur le registre de condoléances
il a tant donné à la ville de modène à
l'italie ve dans le monde entier
c'est ce que j'ai écrit à ton nom mais
que j'ai mis mon nom mon prénom
ciao luciano merci sa voix superbe
continuera à nous tenir compagnie les
montants des vous n'avez j'ai le
sentiment d'avoir perdu quelque chose de
grand même si on ne le perd pas vraiment
ce que pavarotti nous a donné on le
gardera toujours le maire de modène et
l'un des derniers ici à avoir rencontré
le ténor c'était la semaine dernière à
peine et il était très fatigué mais je
voyais en lui une grosse envie de lutter
même si dans son regard
on sentait qu'il était et fusées et on
comprenait que la maladie avait laissé
une empreinte très profonde devant sa
maison des environs de modène serait
désormais le silence
luciano pavarotti avait tenu à vivre
chez lui jusqu'au bout
dans la cathédrale on attend maintenant
l'arrivée du corps une chapelle ardente
va être dressé pour un dernier hommage
les obsèques de luciano pavarotti se
dérouleront ici même samedi après-midi à
la cathédrale de modène on attend une
foule immense
venus de toute l'italie bonsoir roberto
alagna vous êtes une autre grande figure
du chant lyrique merci d'être en direct
avec nous de marseille à quand remonte
votre dernière conversation avec
pavarotti
il ya à peu près 15 jours trois semaines
je lui ai téléphoné je lui ai dit
maestro tu sais je t'aime bien un peu
comme marc uzan avec césar et il m'avait
répondu moi aussi je t'aime beaucoup
voient là et on avait parlé un petit peu
il m'avait mais avait fait quelques
quelques il m'avait donné encore
quelques conseils malgré le fait que je
l'avais appelé comme ça à l'improviste
il a il était d'une lucidité incroyable
c'était un modèle pour vous c'est plus
qu'un modèle je dis toujours que être
ténor ses entrées dans une religion et
lui c'était un peu notre messie à nous
autres ténors c'est lui qui nous a
ouvert la route et il nous a il nous a
montré le chemin
si vous deviez le définir c'est
quelqu'un d'extraordinaire
parce qu'il avait le sens de la
communication du charisme il avait aussi
toujours un côté humoristique et c'était
quelqu'un qui avait toujours le souci du
détail
il ne laissait rien au hasard et c'est
que c'était quelqu'un qui voulait qui
vous apprenait et qui vous apprenait
aussi à vivre pas seulement chanter mais
aussi à vivre à être ténor on disait
aussi de lui qu'il avait un sacré
caractère
oui mais c'est normal parce qu'il avait
une grosse responsabilité
vous savez la voix c'est quelque chose
de très très difficiles à fabriquer
quand on dit dans dans la technique vous
savez mettez un peu de reverb fait s'il
fait ça avec les techniciens les
ingénieurs du son un chanteur d'opéra
lui doit il doit créer tous à lui-même
est ce que vous pensez être son
remplaçant
on peut pas être le remplaçant de
luciano pavarotti personne ne peut le
remplacer par contre s'il ya un héritage
on se passe le flambeau les uns les
autres et je crois que pavarotti m'a
déjà beaucoup fait il m'a donné beaucoup
d'honneur lorsqu'il a fait appel à moi
dans divers reportages ou portraits où
il voulait à chaque fois que ça soit moi
qui qui participent à ces reportages
pour parler de lui
merci roberto alagna d'avoir un cerveau
pris ces quelques minutes pour nous
alors que vous êtes en ce moment à
marseille vous donner des
représentations de marius et fanny à
l'opéra de marseille
et puis j'ajoute que france 2 bouleverse
ses programmes pour un hommage à luciano
pavarotti ce soir à partir de 23 heures
une émission spéciale présentée
justement par eve ruggieri qu'on
entendait il y a un instant des
nouvelles rassurantes de charlotte
gainsbourg l'actrice a été opéré
d'urgence la nuit dernière suite à une
hémorragie cérébrale consécutive à un
accident de ski nautique il y a quelques
semaines seront en époux yvan attal
indique qu'elle pourra quitter la
clinique sans doute dès demain économie
la décision était espéré par la plupart
des investisseurs la banque centrale
européenne renonce à augmenter ses taux
d'intérêt le loyer de l'argent
il faut dire que la croissance est plus
faible que prévu dans la zone euro et
notamment en france on l'évoqué tiers
c'est une déconvenue pour nicolas
sarkozy en déplacement en alsace il a
reconnu pour la première fois ses
difficultés sur place michael darmon
francis forget nicolas sarkozy hausse le
ton à peine arrivé à l'université de
mulhouse
il répond à la question qui l'exaspère
celle du rythme de ses réformes et de la
rupture capote je suis président de la
république est moins de trois mois que
j'ai une majorité et dans les trois mois
et le mois de juillet le mois d'août
coup d'envoi de 48 heures en alsace lui
qui d'ordinaire n'aime pas dormir en
province gouverner pour tous les
français pour tous les territoires
je ne peux pas être enfermé mais à paris
n'ayant pas le belize et ne pas rester à
l'elysée ces jours-ci nicolas sarkozy a
des fourmis dans les jambes
il doit à nouveau se sentir libre de
pouvoir continuer à faire de la
politique c'est pour quoi il en retourne
à colmar comme pendant la campagne
présidentielle oblige les ouvriers
son rythme effréné laquelle vous
travaillez vous croyez que vous allez
réussir à tenir votre mandat comme ça je
n'ai pas à la recherche d'une bonne
croissance perdue nicolas sarkozy défend
sa méthode
avec toutefois une précaution oratoire
nouvelle je sais parfaitement que vous
savez qu'il ya des difficultés
vous savez qu'on peut pas réussir tout
mais j'ai compris au chic vous attendiez
que j'essaye il faut aller à faux à fond
a martelé nicolas sarkozy hier au cours
d'une réunion à l'elysée c'est sa
réponse à ceux qui lui conseillent plus
de prudence en ces temps plus difficiles
même si aujourd'hui il a reconnu une
existence de difficultés économiques
et ce pour la première fois est à noter
qu'un policier du gipn s'est tué en
marge de cette visite il s'agit d'un
tireur d'élite qui est tombé d'un toit
d'une usine 1 colmar
une vaste opération d'évacuation à
aubervilliers la police a délogé ce
matin une centaine de personnes
installées dans des tentes
surprise ces familles ont vu arriver à
leurs côtés rama yade secrétaire d'état
aux droits de l'homme qui s'est déclaré
choqué par la politique de la
municipalité communiste
arnaud beauté marie cazaux
depuis deux mois cent-quinze personnes
logées dans ces tentes alignées le long
d'une école 7h30 ce matin le réveil se
paie brutale la police tente d'évacuer
ces ivoiriens qui sont pour la plupart
en situation régulière
la bousculade va durer plus d'une heure
m
les tentes disparaissent mais pas les
familles 11h nouvelle visite surprise la
sphère franc cette fois une tournure
politique
la secrétaire d'état aux droits de
l'homme bien critiquer la décision
d'expulsion demandé par la mairie ça
prend à la radio que aux bermudes poussé
des gens
donc j'ai improvisé que dix mois c'est
que pour vous dire ne pas donner à tout
ça et qu'on veut mettre tous ensemble
pour travailler à une solution donc
c'est ce que je suis venue chercher mes
l'expulsion est une décision de justice
françois fillon n'apprécie pas
l'improvisation de rama yade
il lui demande ce soir des explications
à la mairie d'aubervilliers on critique
aussi cette démarche
c'est une démarche inutile c'est une
démarche provocatrice
alors qu'elle avait l'occasion de dire
au préfet écoutez fait une table ronde
pour examiner la situation les dossiers
de ces personnes du point de vue de leur
logement
la mairie déclare que faute de place
elle ne peut reloger les squatteurs elle
renvoie à l'état cette responsabilité
ce soir les familles dorment dehors et
se retrouve malgré elle à l'origine
d'une cacophonie gouvernementale
une réunion des autorités de la police
et de la justice pour faire face à la
résurgence des affrontements entre
bandes
le phénomène n'est pas nouveau mais
selon un rapport des renseignements
généraux il serait en augmentation de
29% cours des cinq premiers mois de
l'année et les bagarres on en a parlé en
fait irruption en plein paris pas
d'annoncé particulière l'issue de cette
réunion la ministre de l'intérieur
michèle alliot marie indiqué qu'une
cellule de coordination entre les
préfets de la région ile de france sera
mise en place
alerte au feu cet après-midi dans la
drôme un incendie très virulent a
mobilisé près de 200 pompiers près de
donzère provoquant les embouteillages
monstres l'autoroute a7 a été coupée
dans les deux sens sur place virginie
fichet jean claude martin tout l'après
midi ils ont lutté contre les flammes
et surtout le vent des rafales à 90
kilomètres heure qui ont accéléré la
propagation de l'incendié
c'est dans cette cuisine au bord de
l'autoroute a7 que le feu a pris en fin
de matinée poussé par le vent il a
traversé l'autoroute et la voie de tgv
rapidement il a parcouru une centaine
d'hectares tous les sens et c'était
toute la difficulté de l'exercice être
très longues heures dans cette vallée
ces ventes seulement jeu long et puis
les foyers étaient innombrables 200
pompiers 80 gendarmes ont été mobilisés
cinq canadair deux avions milan
ralentisseurs de feu et des hélicoptères
bombardiers d'eau ont été nécessaires
pour venir à bout le plus vite possible
des flammes menacent et cette habitation
d'un mot voisins ont dû être évacuées ce
n'est que vers 18h30 que l' incendie a
enfin été fixé la mission d'abord c'est
de garder les dispositifs jusqu'à ce que
l'on s'assure que tous les fumées du
moral soit sa bière a battu c'est
surtout de surveiller toute la nuit
coupée pendant plus de cinq heures entre
montélimar et bollène ce n'est qu'en
début de soirée que l'autoroute a7
enfin pu être rouverte un sondage qui va
mettre du baume au coeur des enseignants
et des directeurs d'école en cette
rentrée
88% des français se disent satisfaits de
leur école ou de celle de leurs enfants
et de la formation des professeurs selon
cette enquête tns sofres pour autant la
réforme reste à l'ordre du jour le
ministre de l'éducation xavier darcos je
vous le disais a confirmé ce matin la
suppression prochaine du collège unique
il estime qu'il n'est plus adapté il
s'agit d'un des piliers de notre système
éducatif depuis 1975
explication florence bukiya philippe
muge reins les nerfs ces élèves quel que
soit leur niveau le même enseignement de
la 6e à la 3e
c'est le collège unique instauré en 1975
sous giscard d'estaing l'orientation
professionnelle dès la 5e eh ben
le but c'est l'égalité des chances pour
tous les élèves trente ans plus tard on
sait que le collège n'a pas empêché les
inégalités un élément positif toutefois
pour la scolarisation jusqu'à 16 ans
des expériences qui m'ont porté l'âge
l'âge de scolarisation du jusqu'à 16 ans
ont eu des effets en moyenne bénéfiques
sont créés des difficultés qu'on a du
mal à résoudre mais ont eu en moyenne
donc du point de vue de l'insertion déjà
des effets bénéfiques avec la
suppression du collège unique ressurgit
une crainte que certains élèves soit
orienté avant la troisième si vous
faites ça vous enfermez les enfants dans
une filière comme dans un entonnoir dont
ils ne peuvent plus sortir dans une
filière professionnelle ou technologique
trop tôt et encore une fois vous les
priver de ce minimum d'enseignement
général de culture générale en
mathématiques en histoire en français le
collège unique c'est fini mais le
gouvernement l'a sûr il le remplacera
par un enseignement plus adaptées aux
différents niveaux des élèves
c'est un moyen de s'éduquer ou de se
distraire internet est désormais au
coeur de notre vie quotidienne six
français sur dix l'utilisent
régulièrement et un moteur de recherche
domine le monde
il s'agit de google 400 millions de
personnes utilisent chaque mois soit 51
% du marché mondial
l'entreprise compte quatorze mille
employés voici la méthode google pour
retenir les meilleurs ingénieurs et
maintenir sa suprématie dans les
coulisses du géant d'internet c'est le
dossier de cette édition
il est signé nos envoyés spéciaux en
californie alain de chalvron aaron dimon
on reconnaît le gouveneur l'employé de
google à son appendice informatique
cet ordinateur qu'il ne quitte jamais
dehors dedans ils mangent avec il lit
avec il marche avec c'est parfois un peu
problématique mais c'est ainsi chez
google l'électronique c'est comme
l'oxygène c'est nécessaire à la vie ses
pratiques pour le déjeuner ça sert de
plateau et du coup vous n'avez pas
besoin du plateau de la cafétéria
tout le monde connaît google le moteur
de recherche le plus utilisé dans le
monde en raison de sa rapidité en
quelques secondes il fait le tri entre
des milliards de mots et vous trou ce
que vous cherchez un miracle dû à un
algorithme ultra secret mis au point par
deux petits génies mathématiques les
deux fondateurs de google
toujours à la tête de l'entreprise créée
il y a neuf ans seulement
on les voit tous les jours on les voit à
la cafétéria rouleur présente des
nouveaux projets toutes les semaines qui
sont très engagées de manière à terme
google a grossi démesurément 10000 clics
par jour la première année et millions
aujourd'hui en 24 langues symbolisée sur
ce globe farce est prêt l'entreprise
s'est diversifiée avec par exemple
google earth ou en rachetant des sites
très populaires comme youtube
les effectifs de l'entreprise ont doublé
ces deux dernières années ils sont
quatorze mille maintenant les googleurs
la crème de la crème venus du monde
entier attirés par de bons salaires mais
aussi par des conditions de travail
incomparable sur un campus immense en
californie tu tournes ou là de vis et
attirer et retenir
nous passons beaucoup de temps à
recruter des gens qui sont conformes à
notre culture
et dès qu'on les entre nos murs où veut
les garder nous dépensons beaucoup
d'argent à chercher les meilleurs et on
veut qu'il resterait chez nous c'est
ainsi que les gonfleurs ont à leur
disposition plusieurs salles de sport
comme celle ci où ils peuvent aller à
tout moment sur leur stand travail
cette salle est ouvert 24 heures sur 24
est alors dès que j'ai 20 à 30 minutes
je viens ici c'est bon pour ma
productivité notamment pour la tête
salle de massage piscine à
contre-courant des têtes bien pleines
sur des corps bien fait et tour et ont
même ajouté sur des estomacs bien
remplie
multiples restaurants nourriture
gratuite cuisine du monde et grâce à ce
fameux appendice informatique on peut
même travaillé dans un de ces bars où
l'on 9 toujours gratuitement toutes
sortes de jus d'herbe et bâle
c'est là que je parle m'échapper de mon
travail me concentrer et me sentir bien
et personne ne me demande où je suis ça
qui compte ce sont les résultats
attirer les meilleurs c'est aussi une
question d'image et google soigne la
sienne en californie le must c'est
l'écologie alors google est écolo
panneaux solaires sur tous les toits
vélib dispositions et pris le
substantiel pour acheter une voiture
hybride
il vous donne cinq mille dollars c'est
exactement la différence entre le prix
d'une voiture normale et d'un véhicule
hybride
on comprend mieux pourquoi google figure
régulièrement dans le peloton de tête
des entreprises où les jeunes ont le
plus envie d'être embauchés et en plus
on embauche jusqu'à 100 personnes par
semaine
en bref encore à l'étranger 24 heures
après on découvre les dégâts le cyclone
félix a fait des ravages beaucoup plus
lourd qu'annoncé au nicaragua 38 morts
au moins et 50 mille sinistrés
la région est peuplée en majorité
d'indiens l'aide humanitaire commence à
arriver de l'autre côté de la planète
c'est maintenant le japon qui est
menacée par un puissant typhon
il s'approche de tokyo et la pluie et
les vagues sont déjà très
impressionnante la leyre fait déclencher
image aussi des avions de ligne qui ont
le plus grand mal à se poser sur
l'aéroport l'aéroport qui devrait sans
doute fermer dans les prochaines heures
en europe on parlait de la neige hier ce
sont maintenant des pluies diluviennes
qui s'abattent sur plusieurs pays
ici la roumanie ou cinq personnes sont
mortes et deux autres portées disparues
une ville a été submergée par les eaux
les élections législatives au maroc 15
millions d'électeurs et d'électrices
sont appelés aux urnes demain à ce
scrutin on en parle ici même depuis deux
jours pourrait marquer une percée des
islamistes modérés du parti justice et
développement
alors qui sont ils nos envoyés spéciaux
ont suivi l'un des dirigeants de cette
formation il s'agit en fait d'une
dirigeante reportage dorothée cochard
patrick desmulie
lecture du coran c'est ainsi que débute
tous les meetings du pjd
le parti islamiste modéré le seul parti
islamiste autorisés à se présenter aux
élections législatives qu'elle annonce
suit les religieuses et religieux nous
ont dit que c'était le moins mauvais des
parties bassima hakkaoui et tête de
liste nationale du parti
elle sillonne le maroc jour et nuit deux
petits meetings en grand rendez vous
devant les journalistes étrangers elle
se veut rassurante
son parti a beau se réclamer de l'islam
il ne prône pas la charia la loi
islamique
et pas question de remettre en cause les
avancées économiques du maroc et au team
mate le pjd s'il arrive au pouvoir
continuera les chantiers lancés par les
gouvernements précédents et dans tous
les secteurs que ce soit l'aménagement
du territoire le tourisme ou tout autre
cas pas devant les militants tout acquis
elle est plus radical le pjd dit elle
apportera de l'éthique en politique du
travail aux chômeurs et de l'éducation
aux femmes et pour celui qui ne seraient
pas d'accord qu'il quitte le maroc
est-il ne peut pas qu'ils boivent la mer
tout entière et s'il ne faut pas qu'il
se tape la tête contre les murs
le pjd le grand favori de ces élections
mais il fait peur et pour le contrer le
gouvernement a modifié les cartes
électorales il y à peine un mois
il a redessiné les circonscriptions qui
étaient les plus favorables aux
islamistes
le pjd devrait donc être le vainqueur de
ces élections mais il n'aura pas la
majorité absolue
toujours au maghreb l'algérie a été à
nouveau frappés par le terrorisme est
une bombe a explosé il ya quelques
heures à batna au sud est d'alger il ya
au moins 10 morts et 23 blessés il
s'agit d'un attentat suicide
alors qu'une visite du président
abdelaziz bouteflika était prévue ce
soir dans la région
troisième jour de recherches est
toujours aucune nouvelle du milliardaire
steve fossett aux états unis six avions
et trois hélicoptères se sont relayés
pour tenter de le retrouver dans le
désert du nevada les secours devaient
sont d un lac de la région les sciences
avec cette première en grande bretagne
je vous le disais en titre les autorités
ont donné leur feu vert à la création
d'embryons hybride mi humain mi animaux
il s'agit de favoriser la recherche
médicale
une décision controversée le vatican
dénonce je cite un acte monstrueux à
londres explications maryse burgot
dominique marault tel dans les
éprouvettes de ce laboratoire une
révolution se prépare
ces scientifiques viennent en effet
d'obtenir une autorisation sans
précédent dans le monde
ils vont pouvoir créer des embryons
humains à partir d'ovules d'animaux ils
vont donc par exemple utiliser un ovule
de lapinou de vache
cette ville sera vidée de son noyau à la
place on y injectera des chromosomes
humains alors l'embryon saura-t-il mi
homme mi animal non dit ce scientifique
qui n'a nullement l'intention de créer
des monstres
il restera une infime partie de la vache
mais ce ne sera pas un embryon de vache
ce sera un embryon humain c'est
cendrillon seront de toute façon
détruits au bout de 14
pour interdiction formelle évidemment de
les implanter chez les femmes c'est en
fait uniquement pour aider des patients
souffrant comme cette femme dé maladie
d'alzheimer ou de parkinson que ces
travaux sont autorisés ils permettront
peut-être un jour de créer des cellules
souches utile pour traiter ces maladies
fait scientifique très respecté ne sont
donc pas en train de briser un tabou
absolu celui de la fusion entre l'homme
et l'animal
et ils ont réussi à en convaincre leurs
gouvernements
tout comme l'opinion publique
britannique qui soutient ces recherches
rugby c'est demain que sera donné le
coup d'envoi de la coupe du monde avec
le match france argentine
dans un instant nous serons en direct de
la tour eiffel qui va s'illuminer aux
couleurs du ballon ovale on retrouvera
florent gautreau et fabien galthié
ancien capitaine des bleus
d'abord les derniers instants de
l'équipe de france dans le stade de
france complètement vide le buteur david
skréla était l ouvrage aujourd'hui
nathanaël de rincquesen jean yves blanc
un peu de calme avant la tempête
cet après midi pour le dernier
entraînement des buteurs le stade de
france sonne est étrangement creux
encore une dernière transformation à
blanc pour david skréla demain soir les
points compteront et ils seront 80
milles dans les tribunes à suivre le
ballon des yeux
on sent pas trop la pression rodier et
puis notre part simplement ben ruby qui
fera gagner pour la compétition si les
bleus connaissent le stade de france
comme leur poche
certains argentins s'ils sont un peu
comme dans leur jardin il y a trois mois
sept d'entre eux ont disputé la finale
du championnat de france à augustine
quichotte
le capitaine des pumas argentins a même
inscrit un essai permettant aux
parisiens du stade français de s'imposer
se connaître très bien donc on est les
stades préviennent ça pour ça il est des
symboles il peut ce réaliste et je pense
qu'il y en a j'habite ici et là commence
un peu chez moi aussi à clermont agen à
paris ou même encore à toulouse
les argentins ont investi le championnat
de france à des postes clés et au plus
haut niveau
demain soir au coup d'envoi ils seront
neuf argentins de france sur la pelouse
du stade à guetter les erreurs de leurs
partenaires de club des points faibles
connu de tous et travailler à
l'entraînement par exemple ils jouent en
face de moi donc il me connaît très bien
moi je lui connais très bien aussi donc
je fabriquais des fois c'était plus
difficile mais je crois que tout le
monde on se connaît tous les français se
méfie d'autant que les argentins
présente un bilan plutôt flatteur face à
l'équipe de bernard laporte
ils ont remporté quatre des cinq
dernières rencontres et encore l'an
passé ne se sont inclinés que d'un tout
petit point au stade de france est à 24
heures du coup d'envoi une image
symbolique et sympathique celle de
zinedine zidane qui a rencontré
plusieurs joueurs de l'équipe des all
blacks à marseille et vous le voyez le
jeune retraité s'est initié au drop pas
évident d'ailleurs quand on vient du
football de passer le ballon entre les
poteaux
une coupe du monde c'est toujours de
grands moments la france ne l'a jamais
emporté à la veille de la sixième
édition voici les souvenirs marquants de
trois joueurs christophe duchiron
dominique bonnet
pour ce qui est la coupe du monde de
rugby il y a deux catégories de joueurs
les vainqueurs qui l'ont touché un jour
de joie et les autres qui la regarde
parce qu'ils ont perdu
c'est le cas des bleus et d'abdelatif
benazzi sans trophée mondial mais pas
s'en souvenir
24 juin 1995 à durban et sous une pluie
battante le quinze de france est en demi
finale face à l'afrique du sud
95 et je pense que c'est un des moments
les plus forts de ma vie en fin de
rencontre avec son numéro 6 benaddi à
l'essai de la victoire au bout du bras
ballants aubois vie me tordre les mains
en étant lancée
et là je pourrais vous dire que personne
ne pouvait m'arrêter avec la vitesse qui
était la mienne 100 films s'attendre
était temps devant moi et je trébuche au
lait à cause d'un bleu involontairement
la france rate la finale pour dix
centimètres
le 13 mai 1987 affinait philippe sella
martin superbe et soeurs demi finale
contre l'australie
il sera aussi du sublime mouvement qui
dans les dernières minutes du match
envoie la france en finale
et
après la rencontre les bleus n'en
finiront pas prolonger l'émotion de la
victoire au centre du terrain avec toute
l'équipe d'encadrement tout le public
était parti y avait plus de supporters
plus personne c'était calme à la nuit
tombée et là nous avons chanté beaucoup
de chansons des chansons basques 31
octobre 1999 à londres demi finale
france nouvelle zélande
j'étais en phase de jonah lomu pendant
le haka et je regarde et je me disais je
me dis moment qu'est-ce que je fais là
au cours d'une extraordinaire deuxième
période l'équipe de france réussit sans
doute le match le plus renversant de son
histoire entre autres exploits
bernat-salles marque un essai de 80
mètres au pas de course et s'est dit
peut-être avec ses 77 kg et sa vitesse
qui impressionne les all blacks et jonah
lomu victoire 43 à 31
un jour à marquer d'une pierre bleue
voilà retour au présent avec en direct
de la tour eiffel florent gautreau avait
un côté fabien galthié ex capitaine des
bleus est bien sûr entraîneur du stade
français 1 florent la cérémonie
d'illumination de la tour eiffel va
commencer oui c'est une cérémonie david
en deux parties 1 on va vous expliquer
tout ça mais c'est vrai que en fait
c'est une cérémonie un peu particulière
parce qu'on attend en fait que la nuit
tombe pour que vous voyez quelque chose
pour que l'illumination de la tour
eiffel soit effective cérémonie en deux
parties pourquoi parce que d'abord en
bas de la tour eiffel une couleur verte
va monter peu à peu
c'est une nouvelle illumination un
spécial coupe du monde qui va symboliser
un peu cette couleur le terrain de rugby
la pelouse bien évidemment et puis sur
la partie haute une couleur dorée ça
c'est la première partie et puis ensuite
à partir du moment où le maire de paris
bertrand delanoë va appuyer sur un
bouton magique il en compagnie du
président de la fédération
internationale de rugby syd millar et
président de la fédération française
bernard lapasset
et bien quand bertrand delanoë va
appuyer sur le bouton alors le ballon
ovale géant que vous voyez derrière moi
entre le premier et le deuxième étage de
la tour eiffel va s'illuminer lui aussi
est un écran géant va apparaître sur
lequel on pourra découvrir le sigle
officiel de la coupe du monde de rugby
c'est effectivement le coup d'envoi des
festivités des festivités de cette coupe
du monde était parti fort en effet ils
ont appuyé les oiseaux par ses salariés
alors normes alors normalement ben voilà
c'est parti la couleur verte la couleur
dorée le ballon géant qui s'illumine
également un ballon qui fait 15 mètres
et l'écran géant sur lequel c'est
peut-être difficile à distinguer la
normalement et inscrit le sigle officiel
de la coupe du monde et je vous disais
c'est parti pour six semaines et les
parisiens qui sont présents trocadéro ce
soir il ya beaucoup de flashs qui
crépitent autour et bien les parisiens
le les voies ces nouvelles illuminations
et c'est parti effectivement voyez que
ce sigle officiel david
car évidemment on est à l'ère du rugby
business est en anglais c'est la taille
à celle rugby world cup à yahia est
entre guillemets mais peut-être que dans
six semaines on prendra notre revanche
avec l'équipe de france au stade de
france à quelques encablures d'ici
puisque vous savez que paris la région
parisienne a la chance d'avoir deux
stades
le parc des princes à paris et le stade
de france à saint-denis
voilà en direct du trocadéro sous un
ciel nuageux mais qui fait ressortir les
couleurs à fabien galthié comment
sentez-vous d'abord cette coupe du monde
comment la santé vous pour la france
pour les bleus oui bonsoir david comment
je la sens bien tout à l'heure je
parlais avec syd millar le patron de la
rb l'international rugby board c'est
cela le président du rugby mondial
me disait que l on avait vendu plus de
tickets plus de place qu'un australie
qui avait un grand succès en 2003 on
n'avait pas dépassé les deux millions de
tickets vendus
on était parti comme en 95 % 100 % de
remplissage et on sent vraiment une
motion à votre effort d'humidité y aura
500 600 700 mille visiteurs supporters
qui vont venir qui vont envahir notre
notre pays pour pour assister à ses
compétitions c'est vrai que je crois que
c'est la plus belle des coupes du monde
qui existaient chaque coupe du monde a
été belle mais je crois que celle là
elle est là un destin assez incroyable
et on s'attend en dehors bien sûr un
grand spectacle mais aussi sur le
terrain parce que les équipes sont
prêtes elles ont les coûts du monde ont
lieu tous les quatre ans et ça fait
quatre ans que toutes les équipes
attendent dont l'équipe de france qui a
malheureusement déjà perdu deux finales
perdues aussi deux fois demi finales
jamais très loin et c'est peut être la
bonne année 2007 pour l'équipe de france
de rugby à la fin bien je précise que
vous serez avec nous tout au long de
cette coupe du monde et qu on vous
retrouvera régulièrement d'un point de
vue sportif un peu maintenant prenez des
risques
quel est votre pronostic je vais vous
dire je vais prendre des risques mais
j'ai envie de dire le grand favori
l'équipe qui a dominé ces quatre années
pré coupe du monde le sait les all
blacks et les all blacks sont en avance
ils ont déjà beaucoup de talent mais
aussi aujourd'hui une méthode de travail
une technologie une organisation qui
fait que ce sont les grands favoris de
cette coupe du monde derrière je
passerai l'équipe de france qui qui est
régulière depuis quatre ans qui s'est
bien préparée et sur les derniers
matches amicaux est là elle a dégagé une
forte impression de d'organisation de
stabilité
et psychologiquement elle a l'air elle a
l'air au top surtout que derrière il ya
tout un pays qui va pousser derrière
derrière elle j'ai envie de parler de
l'afrique du sud
oui l'afrique du sud et l'australie qui
souhaite toujours de terribles comme
compétiteurs ils ont déjà été champions
du monde deux fois l'australie une fois
l'afrique du sud et un dernier je
parlerai de l'angleterre qui a quand
même le titre champion du monde à
défendre donc grosso modo autour de 5,6
favori quoi voilà bien merci pour ce
pronostic et puis on se retrouvera à la
fin de la coupe du monde pour voir si
ils se sont réalisés ils se sont
vérifiées on se quitte donc sur cette
belle image d'un ciel un peu plombé un
peu gris à paris mais qui met en relief
cet éclairage de la tour eiffel 24
heures tout juste avant le coup d'envoi
de cette sixième coupe du monde de rugby
merci florent gautreau merci fabien
galthié avant de refermer cette édition
je vous rappelle le principal titre des
hommages venus du monde entier pour
luciano pavarotti le plus populaire des
chanteurs d'opéra à 7 et 1 à l'aube à
modène à l'âge de 71 ans il a est mort
d'un cancer chez lui en italie
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko 20h50 envoyé spécial
avec guilaine chenu et françoise joly au
sommet entre autres le portrait de jean
dujardin et puis retour aussi sur les
incendies du péloponnèse très bonne
soirée
votre soirée sur france 2 jobs d'été
john d'en faire enquête sur les
saisonniers galère il coup de projecteur
sur jean dujardin fasse redescendre hier
j'ai galéré un acteur tout terrain qui
n'a pas fini de vous surprendre
puis france 2 bouleverse ses programmes
et rend hommage avec eve ruggieri aux
plus grands ténors du monde
luciano pavarotti la rentrée d'envoyé
spécial suivi d'un hommage à luciano
pavarotti
bonne soirée sur france 2